[Musica]
inizio chiedendovi scusa perché tutte le
c contenute in questo breve discorso
saranno maltrattate come amiamo fare
dalle mie parti
in realtà cerco solo di essere sciolto
informale ma sono agitatissimo e questo
mi fa venire una domanda non so se
sapete perché si dice me la faccio sotto
dalla paura
voi pensate che una cosa che io ho
scoperto per caso che ha a che fare con
la nostra storia ancestrale quando noi
eravamo bestie della foresta
il nostro corpo si preparava al pericolo
scaricando tutti i pesi in eccesso per
la fuga
questo ce lo portiamo dietro ancora oggi
io soffro di attacchi di panico come
purtroppo tantissimi e la le cose che si
dicono descrivendo la sensazione sono
sempre le stesse
sudo tantissimo vivere la fanno mi batte
il cuore mi sento svenire è la stessa
cosa
è come quando il cervello avverte un
pericolo e allora prepara il corpo alla
fuga aumentano i battiti la sudorazione
il sangue viene sparato nelle gambe e
per questo abbiamo la sensazione di
svenire
è questo quello che siamo siamo bestie
nella foresta e lo siamo ancora oggi lo
siamo ancora oggi o meglio lo saremmo
forse è meglio dire così perché fin da
pochi mesi successivi alla nostra
nascita già alla mamma ci dice no questo
è kakà
questo è brutto questo non si fa i
maestri professori ci danno i voti alla
borsa di studio tela becchi solo con la
lode
il mister ti schiera in campo solo se
sei bravo
il bonus produzione a fine mese e solo
se lavori bene eccetera eccetera
eccetera
e qual è il risultato di questo processo
il risultato è che ci convincono
che dobbiamo essere sempre al top
quindi noi passiamo dall'istinto allo
standard
fortunatamente c'è un
un'occasione in cui riusciamo a scappare
forse da questo meccanismo che il gioco
io ho una fissazione per il gioco fin da
quando ero bambino e pensavo mi sparisse
crescendo invece no 38 anni è tutt'oggi
giocherei di continuo a tutte le ore con
chiunque a qualsiasi cosa tra l'altro in
genere sono una schiappa quindi non lo
faccio neanche per il gusto di vincere
solo che qualche anno fa ho avuto
l'immensa fortuna di fare di un grande
gioco il mio mestiere
io faccio l'improvvisatore teatrale
l'improvvisazione teatrale è un processo
creativo grazie al quale noi mettiamo in
scena storie ambienti i personaggi che
nessuno ha scritto prima è un processo
collettivo quindi si gioca in gruppo a
inventare le cose
questi spettacoli hanno vari format
dipende dalla lunghezza dalla struttura
molti di questi richiamano una gara
sportiva come per esempio il match
d'improvvisazione teatrale che
probabilmente ancora in italia oggi è il
il più famoso questi spettacoli dagli
anni 90 a oggi hanno visto moltiplicare
gli spettatori e anche i praticanti ed è
sempre bellissimo ascoltare il racconto
di chi ti dice che ti racconta la prima
volta in cui ha assistito a uno
spettacolo di questo tipo come
un'apparizione è come vedere la vita che
nasce sul momento è molto meno nobile di
un figlio però c'è la scintilla di vita
e e io mi chiede sempre come mai
come mai uno spettatore così attratto da
uno spettacolo di improvvisazione
perché lì sul palco rivede la bestia
rivede quell'uomo che scatta che è
istintivo che agisce e lo invidia quasi
lo spettatore si attiva si elettrizza
quasi vorrebbe ambire a fare quella cosa
ma dall'altro lato si autogiudica
aggiudicandosi non adatto io non lo
farei mai questi sono pazzi io non ho
fantasia non lo potrei fare ancora una
volta ci dividiamo tra azione e istinto
e raziocinio come se le cose non si
potessero unire invece io oggi vi voglio
dire che tutti improvvisiamo nella
nostra quotidianità
tutti se vuoi uscita la mattina per
comprare il pane il dialogo che
sosterrete col fornaio non ve l'ha
scritto nessuno
e sto parlando di una situazione
quotidiana standard ma pensate a un
evento imprevisto un piccolo incidente
siete ovviamente in grado di sostenere
il dialogo che state per appunto che
state vivendo e le tecniche
dell'improvvisazione teatrale lavorano
quindi sulla fiducia in se stessi sulla
fiducia nel gruppo sull'accettazione
delle idee sulla loro valorizzazione
tutte qualità che secondo me dovrebbero
far parte del buono essere umano non del
buon attore per lavorare su queste cose
abbiamo vari strumenti uno di questi è
dire di sì quasi tutte le scuole di
improvvisazione del mondo concordano con
questa piccola regola del dire sì allora
per farvela capire meglio invece di
parlare facciamo una dimostrazione
e qui ho bisogno di voi ho bisogno che
miur le a te e tutti insieme dei sì
facciamo una prova
ok conto fino a 3 1 2 3
perfetto allora volete che vi racconti
una storia questa storia potrebbe
parlare di un cavaliere questo cavaliere
indossa un'armatura scintillante deve
salvare una damigella e la damigella
damigella è presa in ostaggio da un
drago che sputa fuoco
ma il cavaliere ce la fa e vivranno per
sempre felici e contenti perfetto bene
grazie e complimenti
abbiamo scritto una storia insieme per
quanto qualcuno non fosse d'accordo ma
se vuole può venire qui a raccontare la
sua versione non c'è nessun problema
prendo spunto da questo no che ho
sentito e vorrei fare lo stesso
esercizio al contrario cioè vorrei che
ora mi urlasse dei no ok pronti
volete che vi racconti una storia bene
scusa ok
la morale è semplice con una serie di
ceo forse vado da qualche parte con dei
no non inizia nemmeno ok
quello che mi insegna questo questa
piccola legge è che io so che in scena
devo portare la mia idea senza
giudicarla bella o brutta perché c'è
qualcuno in scena con me che ne farà la
cosa migliore è possibile
e questa cosa lo facevamo tutti da
bambini tutti giocavamo a inventare le
storie si fa che io ero il cowboy e tu
eri l'indiano io ti rincorre roma poi
diventavamo amici tutti lo facevamo e
nessuno di noi si chiedeva se questa
storia fosse bella o brutta originale o
banale tutti portavamo il nostro disegno
all'asilo è veramente lo appiccicava mo
al frigo
nonostante e probabilmente stesse
abbastanza schifo ma per noi era il
disegno fatto per il babbo e per la
mamma chiaro vorrei fare un altro
esercizio è però stavolta c'è bisogno di
proprio un assistente qualcuno e mi
aiuta perché non posso essere da solo
quindi se c'è qualcuno dalle prime fila
dalle prime file si si alza
volentieri ah ok perfetto crede si sta
alzando qualcuno allora tanto introdurre
l'esercizio questa attività
guardala ti danno un microfono credo
questa questo esercizio
l'ho visto fare da francesco lancia in
televisione francesco lancia un
bravissimo improvvisatore romano e non
solo che ha portato questo esercizio in
una trasmissione in cui tentava di
applicare un po di improvvisazione
teatrale in una scuola come ti chiami
noemi piacere
allora noemi è semplicissimo io mi sono
inventato una storia cioè la qui dentro
ok quello che ti chiedo è semplicemente
di farmi delle domande a cui rispondere
sì o no e vediamo se riesci a tirarmi
tirandola fuori
esatto
fammi domande io rispondo sì o no vai
riguarda persone animali scegliere una
che riguarda persone si queste persone
sono tutte dello stesso sesso sì queste
persone sono giovani no
vai vai a queste persone
sono fuori c'è in uno spazio aperto si
ok ma papà vai vai tranquillo andiamo
avanti
questo spazio aperto in questo spazio
aperto ci sono alberi ci si ma fu
registrato retta in questa foresta ci
sono anche animali così ok essere
animali grossi no
qui c'è un gruppo di persone anziane nel
bosco e queste persone anziane guardo
nei piccoli animali e queste persone
amano i piccoli animali no quindi sono
un gruppo di anziani in una foresta
malintenzionati per sé piccoli massi
esatto queste persone hanno fame ci si
sente allora va bene allora non lo
diciamo noi lo diciamo al finale
rimaniamo così grazie mille nomi di
grazie grazie mille grazie
noemi puoi tornare nel mondo delle
persone con troppi i capelli e è
semplicissimo e ovvio che io ho risposto
a caso si e no e ovvio è ovvio che
questa storia se l'è inventata noemi
l'unica cosa che ho fatto io è stato
spostare l'ansia da lei a me se io
avessi preso noi e gli avesse detto
vieni sul palco e raccontami una storia
di 30 secondi
probabilmente non avrebbe fatto mai
magari più estroverse di voi forse
l'avrebbero fatto ma sicuramente se la
sarebbero preparati prima
ok tutto questo per dire che
l'improvvisazione nozze fa parte di
tutti e forse il motivo e anche questo
dovete sapere che l'improvvisazione
teatrale non nasce nell'ambito della
ricerca scientifica
scusate della ricerca artistica non
nasce in teatro nasce nell'ambito
formativo
cioè ci sono dei pedagogisti dei
formatori che in diverse parti del mondo
hanno dovuto mettere a punto tecniche
alternative in situazioni di disagio per
l'apprendimento di tecniche
sviluppassero la creatività
l'empatia la reazione degli stimoli e
per questo che l'improvvisazione parla a
tantissimi aspetti dell'esistenza umana
ed è per questo che oggi noi la possiamo
applicare a tanti
se le situazioni si può lavorare in
contesti di degrado urbano si può
lavorare per valorizzare dei beni
culturali si possono utilizzare tecniche
per l'integrazione dei gruppi di etnie
diverse
si può lavorare nelle scuole come
didattica alternativa si può lavorare
con gruppi di qualsiasi tipo di manager
di attori di sportivi di scout qualsiasi
cosa abbia a che fare con l'area con la
relazione umana può essere potenziato
dall improvvisazione teatrale e pensate
voi siete qui per la maggior parte
scienziati a quanti ambiti di ricerca
potrebbe aprire nel campo della
psicologia della psicodinamica dei
gruppi dell'antropologia e della
sociologia della linguistica di
tantissime scienze cognitive
nell'attesa che questo accada
ricordatevi che tutti intero vediamo
quindi iscrivetevi a un corso di
improvvisazione teatrale e riscoprite la
vostra bestia
[Applauso]
[Musica]